friends was one of the biggest shows of
the 90s when it finally came to an end
in 2004 after 10 seasons it made perfect
sense that NBC would want to continue
its success in some way with a spin-off
the new series which made its debut near
the end of 2004 and was titled simply
Joey focused entirely on Matt leblanc's
character Joey tribiani who moves to
Hollywood to try and make it as a movie
actor the concept made sense but the
execution left a lot to be desired Kevin
brigh one of the original friends
producers believed that NBC had
disregarded his ideas for the spin-off
and made the show less fun than it
should have been ratings plummeted from
the first episode onward and NBC chose
to cancel the series Midway through its
season 2 although official figures about
the cost of making Joey have never been
detailed UK Channel 5 was paying as much
as £500,000 for each episode staggering
five times more than the usual license
fee meanwhile the Blan claims that he
earned $30 million for his role in the
spin-off